you think what like right now uh
half the battle of going up against the
enemy is trying to figure out what his
next three five ten moves are going to
be right and you said something you said
this could get pretty ugly quickly so we
have to make sure we
are moving accordingly with this guy
what do you think are his if you were to
speculate obviously nobody knows we're
not in a man's mind but here's a former
kgb member you're saying he's the
greatest politician on what he was able
to pull off what do you think are his
next three five moves
well i do believe that uh he has
as his
primary goal
uh the occupation of
the eastern part of ukraine
that may include kiev and may not
uh
i if he if he's still
reasoning and smart he knows he can't
occupy all of
all of ukraine without getting into an
afghanistan
type situation
it will eventually
be as undoing
um and and it's not because
there's demonstrations and russians
i think the majority of the russians
don't want this war but it's
you know
the interesting map right here by the
way yeah yep
uh dictators
can be deposed
there there's
palace crews in history all over the
place
and uh
putin needs to be aware that
i'm sure he is aware that the the his
inner circle
they're powerful people
and and he needs to
uh find a way to stay at the top
that means
uh you know
he showed proper aggression because he
they're looking for a strong man
uh but he can't
get to a point
where
uh his his
his rule is eroded because of uh the
quagmire in ukraine
so i heard this morning um
that uh
uh there are negotiations going on where
there is a little more
uh
realism in the demands on on either side
i think he needs to find an off ramp
if he doesn't
he's done
elaborate on he's done unpacking he's
done as a person as an individual
they think someone's going to take him
out
uh yeah
you mean not not immediately and and
maybe not necessarily killing but you
know
taking him out because he has he
politically taking him out or
politically or literally taking him out
no no politically
uh did you see that there's a picture in
the in the media where he's surrounded
by
uh all his bodyguards i mean
they are the best trained
uh uh
commandos in the world i would think so
he would be hard to take out unless
and
i'm not advocating any of that
unless you know where he is and and
throw a nuke into that you brought up
his inner circle right the russian
oligarchs i don't know maybe political
well look at the international generals
the uh the the the
intelligence services they all have
power on their own who do you think he
actually listens to
nobody really knows that right
and there's also no uh no clear
succession plan
you know he's going to be 70 very soon
it's not clear who would succeed him so
that's he's going to be in power until
2036 i believe if you live that long
that's a weakness of the state if you
don't have succession but it could be
chaotic once once he disappears
it's it's the the the future of russia
doesn't look very good because right now
economically he's he's getting killed
crushed yeah 60
crushed absolutely 40 the
currency is dropped in the last whatever
eight nine ten days
and they want to get 60 trillion rubles
back from the people that's insane if
you do something like that what's this
right here lindsey graham stands by call
for someone in russia to assassinate
putin i saw that a few days ago right he
should shut up already you can say that
in private lindsey graham yeah
but by the way you saw you saw the fact
that an insider from russia released
information that there's already been
three assassination attempts on zelinski
uh oh and
nova and then the questions ask how many
assassination attempts have been made on
putin nobody knows right because it have
to be from the inside yeah yeah but
there's already been three by the way
you know how many assassination attempts
there was on hitler 42 plus
yeah and eventually he killed himself
killed himself yeah so do you have an
opinion on who you think putin would
listen to
i i i think i think putin's a true
believer you have to negotiate with true
believers in a different way like you
ever talk to somebody and you say but
you don't understand what he did
but you will never understand it but you
will never understand no matter what you
say that person goes to what but you
will never understand it like there's so
much
emotion behind it how do you eliminate
all that emotion
if if that's any like like
parents get a divorce my mom and dad got
a divorce no matter what's said
that
the emotion is so deep between the two
nobody can do anything about it right
it's that deep of what that emotion is
you just heard the history of what
happened with russia and how it went
back and forth and how he views ukraine
and what he thinks of ukraine you know
what he thinks about him
he looks at zelinski and he says this is
not a leader i would do laps around this
guy how do you guys buy
into an actor being your president who
created a political party on a tv show
and he starts uh
don't look at trump but but i i told him
but to him yeah you got to think about
to putin to putin is like who are you to
sit across like who do you think you are
you're a nobody putin's a true believer
so
you know for me i already said it
yesterday when we talked about it i
think the best offense is what what
what's that
a good defense america had a good
defense prior to biden
america had a pretty good defense prior
to biden biden's not scaring anybody so
everybody's playing offense because our
defense sucks right now
defense is how you handle afghanistan
that's a terrible defense
we did not have a good defense you don't
intimidate anybody when you don't have
so
what do we do about it so he's being
opportunistic about it
my only concern is again it goes back to
the same thing my only concern is
how far is he willing to go out the
reason why i called jack this week and i
said jack we want to have you on and we
we just called you this week by the way
maybe sunday or monday no it was friday
actually monday was monday okay it was
monday so monday two days ago right i
said i'm going quick yeah and we we flew
him out because i want to know what he's
thinking and i want to know what his
moves are going to be
what what is a formula yeah i want to
know what
is is how much of it is a bluff game
how much of um we don't know that's what
i'm saying
you've used the analogy multiple times
that he's you know he's got pocket twos
and he acts like he's you know has a
straight in his hand you've used this
analogy yeah i i wonder like is he
bluffing because
he's so in too deep now
that it's very hard to paint a picture
for him to redeem himself history may be
done with him so if you enjoyed this
little segment from the podcast click
over here to watch the entire podcast
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so take care everybody
[Music]